job coach Brad Jones told me at halftime
that you guys were executing the game
plan beautifully in that first half
what's the most important thing in that
game plan that you needed to execute to
win this game Oh me personally I think
it was our energy oh we did execute the
game playing well but because of our
energy that intensity was out there
playing with we'll find around
scrabbling blocking shots rebound and
getting out of run that's how we want to
play tonight we would lock in you learn
from last night that we got to play all
48 minutes and tonight we did
you've talked the last couple of games
about this team not lacking confidence
that hasn't been a problem at all this
season who's responsible for that I feel
like we all talk to each other even the
coaches staff coach let us play with a
lot of freedom as you can see everybody
have the green light so I mean it's no
no reason to lack confidential you have
a coach who believed in you every step
of the way and let you go out there play
your game so we always just appreciate
oh keep shooting if make or miss and we
behind you so you went large tonight how
much you put on yourself to end this
skid that you guys were in man the
losing streak kind of you know is eating
me up I felt like I could have been
better in a lot of places and I'm
thankful for it is this guy who tweeted
and said I'll have that fire in my no
more that game right else for him that's
what I do I prove people wrong each and
every night and that's for him right
this congratulations great game tonight
Josh